don't have that background because you
don't have that history and as long as
loyalty is there first and foremost and
that you would treat man so you would
treat your men
as men don't wrong they have to be men
in the first place and by men I mean
actual masculine men they have to have
the right frame they have to have the
finances in order but
as long as they can see that you have
the right history you have the right
motive and then the loyalty is there
altogether
I think we could all agree here that
that relationship is now going to last
and it's going to be fruitful forever
what's more what's more important a low
body count or loyalty
what's more important
I don't think I need to pick either one
they tend to be the same I've got to say
they kind of they go hand in hand
because if a girl has a higher body
count it's more baggage it's more
ecstasy has to deal with it's more at
like I hate this term but like Alpha
widows
I've never heard that it's yeah it's
basically like the x that the girl can't
get over but there's more of them the
more people she slept with I do agree
with certain points that you said about
game I do agree with body count and I do
I was raised on women shouldn't get run
through and I do agree with that and
I'll preach that to my daughters but I
don't what I don't agree with is
the perfect family the scenario the
greatest thing for a woman is when she's
standing in her living room the 30
people celebrating her
yeah for some people yeah for some
people that is that is their life goal
[Music]
I think
my I've got a few people in my family
that can't have kids
so that's the exception that's the
exception no and that's an exception so
it's to say is to say she can't have
kids her life is any less fulfilled than
my other Auntie that has got that maybe
maybe but she's living her best life on
in foreign like is she she's had she's
had to adjust the ultimate yeah I hear
you so we can adjust and I don't think
her life is any less fulfilled no it's
not it's not going to be no it's not
going to be an illness with Phil I mean
technically it will be
unfortunately probably periods of her
life where she's one of the kids right
but but again I mean that is the
exception sort of rule and it doesn't
mean she can't be happy but she's not
going to be as happy now that's just the
sad truth of it right but if if you're a
woman I mean to go back to your previous
Point what would a woman want more than
to later on be able to say that they're
a grandmother great grandmother with
loads of loads of kids load of people
that have come from them what will I
know you said that that's not every
woman's goal what goal would you say a
woman would value more than that long
term that Society has told her she
should have yeah
um like I wouldn't I want to cut the 30
grandkids 30 great grandkids down to
like eight nine because the cost of
living out here is crazy yeah that's a
lot of Christmas presents but the point
is the point is if women doesn't
prioritize a family she ends up unhappy
in the long term in general
like like because this is when you
survey women because it's it's all fun
and games when you're still hot right
and you still look good right and you
still get attention from men but at some
point that goes away like no guys are
lining up to date 50 year olds yeah and
you're gonna live to be 90. go ahead
yeah sorry and we have that window so
that's why we want that commitment
fertility window yeah yeah so we need to
we need to optimize in that and try and
find that commitment when we're in that
window so then so women want women are
nurturing they want to have kids
naturally not all not all natural
naturally you do
but I believe the only reason why some
women will say they don't and I I
personally believe I'm yet to be
convinced otherwise is because modern
day social conditioning Society has
convinced you that's not your ultimate
goal but if you actually walk into a
dark room with nobody in there by
yourself completely quiet and ask
yourself what do you want what is your
biology want I think you'll know the
answer when you ask girls that are 18
and they're graduating high school they
all want to be married with kids that's
the first thing they want yeah but who
sold them that dream
as well it's definitely not Society
you're feminism pushing you can get your
own bag female empowerment like I've
been told from the youngest age that I
can do whatever I want Society is
telling you that you should have this
big career yeah and make it on your own
and [ __ ]
it's not all you want you're just gonna
if you're gonna be like a a high up
lawyer with loads of money you may have
loads of money but you'll be lonely
because you won't have
your children you get a couple of more
holidays a year out of your money so
[ __ ] what at the end of the day what
does it matter to you if you've not got
a family that's ultimately what you want
to have children I mean it's the gift we
have yeah
you're breeding machines that's
literally what you're biologically
designed I know this but I want to ask
you guys something here now the LGBT
community yeah should be allowed to
conduct themselves how they conduct
themselves right so we more than likely
we're not going to get any kids from
that area yeah yeah now the women that
we're now telling go to work go to
career and stuff don't have kids late
now we're telling those women not to
have kids what do you think happens to
the human race when people stop having
kids
that's what I'm talking about so we need
a man and a woman to have kids right
right otherwise we need to continue the
human race and to touch so it sort of
cut you in but so it's going but on that
point people have got to understand that
what we're fed to believe we want and
what we want on a DNA level cellular
level are two different things and this
brings me back to the very point you you
all touched on earlier with regards to
what men are looking for in women and
what women are looking for in men now
this is just for anybody watching at the
end of the day the simple breakdown I
provide for people is if you're if
you're if you're a man
for any man in this room if I was to sit
here and break down a woman so for
example
I would say she's
she's very very caring she loves her
career yeah right she's very very driven
she's got loads of friends around her
that love and respect to her family her
daughter pieces Highly Educated what is
every single man in this room thinking
right now
in what sense if I was to describe a
woman and start off and purely lay out
those
um attributes or traits or her history
right what what for any guy in here or
any guy listening what question do you
have in mind what's the first question
you have what does she look like thank
you very much right it all comes down to
the Aesthetics in the beginning right
now for women it is slightly different
in that
now if I was to say
he's
a great looking guy
chisel jaw
big dick
tall
why what does he do well thank you very
much yeah you've broke so the first
thing you want to know who is he what
does he do what his connections what's
his status right in society I think deep
down every single woman asks those
questions and if I was to say along with
those things
if I was to drop it on you now say that
he's a complete bum he's going nowhere
in life he still lives in his mum's
basement and he's got no drive to
accomplish anything in life nobody
around him respects him he's got no
friends and there's no goals trying to
hit him up what would you say now
get the [ __ ] away from me is what you're
saying
I always said we shouldn't say hypergamy
isn't a bad thing
hypergamy is designed for our survival
yeah exactly I don't want to date a bomb
like I I hope to God you guys don't want
to date bombs so you're saying guys
would date a girl who's bummy
well at least that's what a girl a woman
being a bum to us well we don't really
look at women as bums for us it's more
to do with your loyalty yeah and it's to
do with your attitude in life whether
you're arrogant whether you've got that
overly confident nature to us it's
repulsive but a woman having no money
and a woman not being well connected do
you think we give a [ __ ] because that's
not our ultimate goal ultimately on a
DNA level and this is what most men need
to understand this is what we act on
it's Primal it's on a DNA level we are
ultimately after
good breeding stock so you need to have
and this is this is a woman's display of
good breeding stock good genes is by
having a great physique a beautiful face
she's youthful she's young she's within
that Peak fertility window
she does have a clock the sooner like
that that will run out and then she'll
she'll end up on the other side of that